pretty much for hanging around and I
suppose before we start thanks to the
lacteal office and their staff and the
jela and everybody who's completed of
things here very scruffy tonight for all
the work that goes in to the election to
before a start they were also late to to
thank Margaret and the priya's Margaret
for a lifetime of public service there's
a lot of people in Saudi who don't who
had their lives positively affected by
the work that's used on politics is
across border times
so certainly I wish you all the best for
the future and thank you for being
injured on public service
[Applause]
we are now entering a new year in South
Zone is an historical action it is the
first time a Republican has ever been
elected as MP for South Zone
[Applause]
and ways and ways Dame honored an
entirely privileged that it is me I'm
very aware that I'm standing on the
shoulders of heroes people that have
went before us and I want to dedicate
this win to dear friend Vincent
MacDonald who passed from us just this
year but this is also a huge win for
people like McMurphy for Katrine early
on for Frank Whittle and those who
tirelessly worked over many years
through the barren times and through
tough times to spray a dish in feed
message and I'm delighted that is
resonated so positively and so popularly
this year but the message now for shin
feein and for the people of South Dane
is not one step back through shoots
challenges we fight praxis we fight Tory
austerity under huge opportunities for
young people too so I am entirely
humbled to receive such a boat and I
can't wait to get stock in or a millaa
millaa millaa
[Applause]